All right. Well, apparently while I was out,...
...somebody got into the kitty cat treats.
I gotta go look at the suspects.
Suspect number one.
Was it you, Macy?
Let's see your face.
Did you do this?
Did you?
I don't think you did.
Number two.
What? Did you do this?
Denver, did you do this?
Denver, was this you?
Denver, you won't look at me.
Did you? What?
Denver, did you do this?
Look at me.
Come here.
Let me see.
Let me see your face.
Oh my goodness! Denver, you didn't!
You did this?
You got in the kitty cats' treats while I was gone?
I can't believe it!
Are you sorry about it?
Okay, you know the routine.
In the kennel.
Go on.
I'm very disappointed. You're in the penalty box.
You let it happen.
I hope you're happy too.
Geez!